session and the first talk is by dsha
adir so
yeah okay thank you for coming this
early in the morning and I'm going to
speak about some fast algorithms for
regression problems so um this is all
based on joint work with some of my
collaborators some of them are here in
the audience so it's Brian Rasmus
Richard and sushant and these are based
on a bunch of works over the
last couple of years and I hope to give
a summary or like an easy summary of all
of these okay so just to set the
notation let's start with uh like the
basics so what do we aim to do in
regression so let's say you have some M
data points and they all have n
parameters so let's think of it as you
have more data points few parameters and
the goal is you want to figure out okay
which curve fits this data the best like
which goes through it the best
minimizing some
distances so in
um most of these so let's just call
these points you know a i j so um like
think of a as these row vectors and you
have these labels on each of these data
points
and now um then most of the common
studied things which is linear
regression you assume that okay there's
a linear curve that fits this data and
you want to figure out what that linear
curve is uh to be a little more formal
you assume there's
some there some linear relation and you
want to minimize this error vector and
the standard formulation asks you to
just minimize the ukian norm of this
error vector and this we know how to do
exactly there's a nice closed form
solution for this um but in some
applications you might actually want to
think of instead of minimizing the ukian
norm you think of some other function of
the error that you want to minimize and
let's look at some so so one example oh
sorry one example is just that okay
instead of looking at the ukan norm
let's minimize the lp Norm of the error
and an example where this actually might
be useful
is so let's think of a graph and the
goal is to send one unit of flow say
from X1 to X5 and you want to minimize
some sort of energy so given this graph
you want to find values that minimize
you know some energy which is usually
can be thought of as the electrical
energy for
those algorithms and this can actually
be cast as a regression problem and you
can think of it as can exactly formulate
this in uh um like okay minimize some
quadratic term under some um constraints
with very few constraints and this
Matrix is just the edge vertex incidence
Matrix and you can also you know
translate this to the formulation we
were looking at but now this is more
like oh you have very few labels you
have very few this B Vector is really
small um and you have like a lot of data
points
right so this is more like they setting
where very few labels now if you want to
fit something in these kind of models uh
there's this paper that runs some
experiments along with studying some
algorithms so they look at different
values of P while trying to minimize the
pnorm of the error vector and so this is
more like in two- dimensional space they
take some 10 to the five uh points and
only two of them have labels and when
you plot the the labels like in 2D space
you can see that when p is two it's like
you along the label points you have two
spikes so this is not a good fit in that
sense but as you keep increasing P it
becomes more and more like a linear
surface so in some settings it so in
these settings like more in terms of uh
this is more this exact problem was more
in the context of graphs semi-supervised
learning in graphs so in these cases it
has at least been shown that for
different P for larger values of P you
can actually fit it much
better so uh there are some other things
people can use which is something like
logistic regression which is mostly used
in the case of classification and then
this is like soft Max regression which
is used in terms of finding smooth
approximations to the max Norm but let's
focus today on pnorm regression for
let's say p larger than 2 um to
right so our formulation to be so we'll
focus on this formulation where a is
this tall and thin Matrix so you have
more constraints less
variables and B is the labels on these
um like on these data points and yeah so
yeah the goal is to just find a vector X
that
minimizes okay
so um okay so an equivalent and easier
formulation which we will use is you
know the instead of the over constraint
setting we'll just look at the under
constraint setting and I claim that
they're both equivalent uh you can
translate from one to the other and for
ease of notation we'll use this but all
the algorithms I present directly work
for the over constraint setting as well
so in this case we're just looking at
okay minimum this is more like you have
a hypers hypers plane and you want to
find a point on the hyper plane that
minimizes the lp Norm of um that that
has the minimum LP so now a is a short
fat Matrix and let's say it has
Dimensions n by m and the the variable
has M coordinates so look at this
setting for
now yeah okay so some more um advantages
of of LP Norms so it easily captures the
ukian norm yeah the standard linear
regression which we know how to solve
exactly um when p is one it's equivalent
to linear programming and when p is
infinity it captures like uh Max flow
linear programming and a bunch
of so as P tends closer to one when p is
less than two closer to one you tend to
get more and more sparse Solutions and
as p is large as we saw in the example
you kind of get more U flat Solutions
towards for
applications okay good so before I get
into algorithms are any
questions so p is at least one yeah p is
but U most of the algorithms I'm going
to present would will just look at P
greater than two we can
okay so to formally State the goal so
given some Epsilon what we want is we
want to find some X that satisfies the
constraint so you want ax equals B and
you also want that theorm of X is at
most a multiplicative Factor away from
the optimum and we also want to be able
to do this in you know some runtime
that's polinomial in M which is the size
of the variable and we want to be able
to converge geometrically so you want a
log 1 by Epsilon convergence the
advantage is in this case you can
basically solve to a polom high accuracy
with only like poly log overhead so this
would allow us to these These are
usually termed as high accuracy
Solutions and because of this you can go
you can actually converge really close
to not just the objective but also the
solution value in most
cases okay and we would use the fact
that we know how to solve this problem
for p equals 2 which is just solving one
linear
system okay so some of the previous
Works um they were all based on some
convex programming ellipsoid methods
they can all obtain high accuracy
Solutions but the they Bas they required
some polinomial in M time which was not
a small
polom uh the work of NE nesterov and
neosi in 1994 was based on interior
Point methods and these were these
problems they were able to reduce
solving um the lp regression problem to
just from square root M uh linear system
soles so it has root M iterations each
iteration is solving an L2 problem or
like a linear system
um so this was till 1994 we knew this uh
further in 2018 stock 2018 uh bbec Kohan
Lee and Lee they give a new homotopy
method so this can do better than ipms
especially for small values of P so ASM
totically it is it instead of M to the2
you now have m to the 1/2 minus 1 by 3
and ASM totically this is the same as
IPM for p closer to one and close to
Infinity but for other values of P close
to let's say four five or like some good
values this is significantly better so I
can see this
here
and and you can see that this is kind
this this problem is kind of symmetric
around two and yeah so basically this is
the Dual of P Norms is just some P by P
minus one norms and these are metric
around two so you see
this okay so the first thing I'm going
to talk about is a faster algorithm that
we gave a few years ago and this is able
to obtain a high accuracy solution but
it's faster than the known method so ASM
totically instead of going to m to the
1/2 we now convert uh in m to the 1/3
iterations to the optimum and we still
get a high accuracy
solution and this is not just ASM
totically for all values of P you can
actually do better uh there was a
there's also this uh work by bullins in
2019 which does which obtains this optim
this faster rate for p equals 4 and
that's based on a completely different
set of uh techniques more optimization
based and these are yeah I'll get into
how we get
these and we also believe this rate is
Optimum though it's still open to proof
so given only that given that you can
only solve linear systems we believe
this rate is Optimum um and it's also in
some context they have proven a lower
bound which I will get to a little later
in the talk but not in this
exact okay so you may ask does this
imply faster linear programming because
P equals 1 and infinity correspond to
linear programming and the answer is no
because we have these factors of P
linear some P squ or P factors in the
runtime you can actually improve this to
a factor P so P must be away from one
and infinity and it's still a big open
problem if you can do m to the one third
um iteration algorithm for
one high accuracy in the high accuracy
region and okay so now let's look at the
algorithm so the first algorithm it's
basically has two key components the
first part which is iterative refinement
this helps us get the high accuracy part
the second part is a fast multiplicative
weight update solver and that allows us
to improve from m to the 1/2 to m to the
1/3 so let's start with what we mean by
iterative refinement uh before I do this
are there any questions
okay so iterative refinement I mean
originally studied for linear for just
the L2 non problem it just means that if
you're at some point x and this is your
problem you take a step you go from X to
X Plus Delta you
can reduce this to just solving this
problem which is just a quadratic
problem and we'll term this as the
residual
problem and if you can solve this
residual problem to some approximation
let's say a Capa approximation you can
solve the original problem to um any
accuracy you want with just Capa log M
by Epsilon um
iterations so this idea was uh for for
simple L2 regression problems this
follows through you just have to solve
another quadratic problem why is this
easier is a different question and we'll
see why does this help for LP
regression and this idea has also been
used um for smooth and strongly convex
functions especially in optimization so
where you instead of um writing this
exactly as a quadratic you can give nice
quadratic Global upper bounds which
comes from smoothness and you can also
give nice quadratic lower bounds which
follows from strong convexity and once
you have the same kind of Upper and
Lower bounds you can basically oh sorry
can show that you can find minimizers to
the upper quadratic problems and all you
need is some L by some something like a
condition number and some log one by to
con to high accuracy
Solutions and you can also do this
approximately you don't really need to
minimize the upper bound um exactly so
any approximate solution would just
entail an additional C
Factor yeah rate of
conversion okay so the problem with LP
Norms is since we know how to solve
quadratic problems we would ideally want
upper and lower bonds that are quadratic
but for LP Norms you can't say anything
it's too steep Beyond a certain point
and it's too flat around the origins so
you can't have any kind of quadratic
approximations so the hope is okay can
you give any Global upper bound and the
same kind of global lower bound because
if you have that we could use some of
the ideas of these iterative refinement
and hope to do the same kind of thing
and the answer is yes we can actually
yeah this would allow us to Simply
convert a constant approximation to a
high accuracy solution and the answer is
say yes we can actually give good
envelopes
so um we can write upper so we basically
can yeah the answer we could actually
find some good envelopes
and then you can just minimize the upper
bound approximately and you converge it
hopefully
this okay so how do we construct these
good envelopes so let's look at the
simple case of P equals 4 and let's look
at one coordinate
and you just write a tailor series
expansion of like 1 plus
del4 and you knowe that so look at these
terms so this term is basically a linear
approximation which is just the gradient
term you have some local
curvature uh which is defined by the
hesan and the last term this defines how
the function grows in the long um like
far from the original point and we claim
that it's actually this these three
terms are enough to give a global
approximation and can show that you can
actually just lower and upper bound
these by the linear term some Factor
times the local curvature and these
terms that defect the long range
Behavior so it's essentially the
gradient the hesan and the P2 the P term
in the um
expansion so this actually captures the
long range behavior and you know the
local quadratic even if you plot it
out so yeah this so This extends to you
know any X and Delta and it also extends
to all values of P so you
can basically write this so you can um
lower bound and upper bound this by the
same terms the gradient
the hen and
the good so once we have these uh so
this gives us good envelopes so now you
can choose to minimize this upper bound
to a Capa approximation and you just do
this some log 1 by Epsilon times and you
convert to a high accuracy solution and
yeah we'll see and this this is
essentially the same you can see that
this is again like some quadratic plus P
term but it turns out this is easier to
work with than just having
OB um easy way to think of that is this
is somehow more structured at least
around
the and the other Advantage is we only
need to do a very crude approximation to
this
problem okay so so far we have shown
that we have this residual
problem and
we just need P Capa log 1 byon
problem
okay are there any
questions okay so now let's see how we
actually solve the res
problem so yeah you have a linear
quadratic and P term uh the first thing
we can do is you can do a binary search
over the linear term so we could just
convert this
to just minimizing under some linear
constraints you have a quadratic and
a and we want to use the fact that we
know how to solve these problems so if
this is like the lp ball you want to be
able to solve some number of quadratic
problems and approximate the solution
so a simple multiplicative weight update
solver so we'll use multiplicative
weight update solvers and we'll the
basic multiplicative weight update
solver uh if if would just do the
following you just take some iterations
you look at this quadratic problem the
one that we know how to solve and you
just build the solution you just update
the solution every time based on the
solution you get from the
quadratic and you upate some you know
these weights that we
have and in the end you can return the
average of this so this is a standard
multiplicative weight update template if
we fit it into our problem
um we so if we fit this into our problem
you can note that the solution so we are
solving this problem at every iteration
this solution
can um can actually be off by a factor
of M to the2 just because it's almost
like you're solving a L2 you're trying
to approximate an L P problem with an L2
so this is something like M2 the1
approximately M2 the2 so you would need
about m to the 1/2 iterations to get
some to to get the solution down to at
least a constant value so this algorithm
if analyze this this converges in some m
to the 1 12 itations and but if we
actually want to do
better uh we do the small trick which is
also known as width reduction and it's
originally seen in the context of Max
flow uh about 10 years ago and the trick
is okay so if you have something that if
you get a solution that has a large
value so if you have a solution that has
a small P Norm then you build your
solution otherwise for every coordinate
that is large
you just penalize the weights by a
l and it turns out that this trick gives
you an m to the 1/3 rate of convergence
and it will return a constant
approximate solution to your
problem all right so what we really did
was you have this problem we converted
by to just minimizing the quadratic plus
the P term and get rid of the linear
term bya binary search and you can use
this fast multiplicative weight update
solver to get a constant approximate
solution to this
problem all right so overall you can
find a constant approximation in some pm
to the 1/3 linear system
solves and this gives us a 1 plus
Epsilon approximate solution to and
overall some p^2
m
can use some other tricks to actually
reduce this p² to P but we can that for
now right so um you may ask what was
really special about LP Norms that
actually lets us do these two things and
the answer is that you can actually
extend these to some structured problems
that have the same kind of structure as
regression and the so the main ideas we
just used were finding good Global
envelopes and this fast
solver and the property so the main
bottleneck is maybe this finding a fast
solver that gives like which functions
are um incorporable in these fast
solvers and a sufficient condition is
quasy self-concordance which we also saw
on Monday in R talk which is some kind
of higher order
smoothness kind of assumption on the
functions so in simple onedimensional
setting it just means that the third
derivative is bounded by some Factor
times the second derivative and this is
slightly different from self concordance
in self concordance you have a 3x2 a
power on the second derivative
but yeah for our purposes you only need
to bound the third derivative by the
second derivative and this does capture
some important functions that are
studied which is like softmax it
captures logistic regression and it also
captures L regularized LP regression so
this is the kind of function we were
looking at for our fast Sol
work so these
um so right so the key property of why
these quasi self concordant functions
are useful is the fact that it actually
implies this property of hesan stability
so that means that if two points are
Clos in space uh the hesion of those
points are only like a small
multiplicative factors okay and this
property actually allows you to uh say
that the function is locally quadratic
so at least in like small L2 balls or
depending on which Norm you're working
with in small regions you can your
function is very well behaved it's both
kind of it it has both quadratic upper
and lower
bounds right and this allows us to give
a width reduced algorithm for all FY
self-concordant functions so let's recap
what we saw for LP you had these few
iterations we were solving this
quadratic problem which was just the hen
essentially the you were solving this is
just the hen of the function and if this
was small the solution had a small Norm
you were updating it and if it was large
then you penalize the
weights so for General functions can use
the same idea now you solve this
quadratic problem but now you have
this some regularized h of the function
that you're looking
at and you look at the norm of the
solution so if this Norm is small so
this is like m to the 1/3 this normous
small You're Building Your solution and
you're just updating your weights but if
this is large so then you look at all
coordinates that are large and you
penalize the thing you're solving here
and yeah and in the end you just return
the average of the solution you
form so you can think of this as a
primal step and this as a soall dual
step of optimization and we can prove
that is basically
give you a rate of convergence of some m
to the 1/3 and some constant so you can
find a constant approximation and some m
to the
1 so these kind of algorithms have
actually been seen in many context so we
have seen it in the um sense of so we
have seen it for Max flow um you've also
seen so these have also been seen for
some Matrix scaling applications
and some
again the metri scaling operator scaling
kind of problems and what we but they
all have these very different specific
potentials that they use so what we
actually show is that you can give a
unified potential analysis
and so you can do a unified potential
analysis and that captures all qu self
concordant functions and it gives us
these rates for so for Infinity
regression you can do m to the 1/3 by
Epsilon to the 5/3 for LP regression we
recover the rate we know and for
logistic regression again you can do the
and okay so the key ideas are again we
extend these multiplicative weight
update algorithms and you need a new
potential and unified potential analysis
that can handle all of these and there's
also to since these multiplicative
weight update schemes only give you like
constant approximations you also need a
way to boost these to higher through
high accuracy Solutions and you can give
a new version of iterative refinement
but the difference now is you can't get
these Global upper and lower bonds so
you have to work with local bonds and
with these local bonds which can be
turned as some box constraints you can
uh boost these to high accuracy
Solutions
okay so um now uh I'm going to talk a
little more about what else can we get
from iterative refinement it's not just
the high accuracy Solutions but it has
some more interesting
consequences so usually okay so now so
far we were just solving these LP
regression problems using called linear
regression like just solving L2 problems
and that um since the gap between these
Norm is something like m to the 1/2
you're able to speed it up to m to the
1/3 but suppose you could use some
higher P suppose you want to solve the
L10 Norm using some L4 Norm or something
so the gap between these Norms is
already low but um classically if you
just have these LP
problems you cannot directly solve these
these give you a factor of some m to the
P by q and this is actually large so if
you think of PS4 and Qs
login oh sorry oh I think the other way
around want P to be l in and Q to be
four then this factor is basically quite
large
but you can the the thing you can show
is that um you can solve with an extra
factor of M to the 1 by P minus 1 by q
and this is small and if you use
problems of this form so instead of just
directly solving the p and Q if you use
a regularized version you can solve
these um so you can directly
solve this problem using something
that's minimized x² + x to the Q for any
p and Q you can do that with only an
overhead of 1 by
P and this is good in the sense that if
you we go back to our iterative
refinement framework we created these
residual problems now if p is very large
you can just reduce it to solving for
the log N Norm problem and you can solve
that so this basically lets us uh get
rid of one p factor in the
overall so yeah you can solve the Q
residual
problem that directly gives you this
approximation and this allows us this
gives some relation for different uh for
different problems for different P
values and for large P we just solve the
login okay so yeah this allows us to you
know give this linear in pm to the 1/3
linear
system okay so one more
uh advantage of using these
multiplicative weight kind of Frameworks
where you're solving linear systems is
you can use uh like these these routines
or these data inverse maintenance data
structures that kind of um that allow
you to speed up algorithms by not
solving the quadratic problem at every
iteration so
the current time we have that solves
this is something like m to the 1/3 +
Omega where Omega is the uh matrix
multiplication time and we can design
data structures by using some inverse
maintenance that solves this in some
poly log m m to the Omega time and all
of this is possible because we only need
to solve the residual problem to a
constant approximation or a log M
approximation and this allows us to find
high accuracy LP regression in some m to
the 2.33 + m to the Omega and this for
the current matrix multiplication is let
just
the okay so on uh graph problems which
are let's which are like nicer instances
we can do a lot better so let's look at
these problems where you again want to
send one unit of flow from some s t but
now instead of minimizing a quadratic
energy you're minimizing the lp energy
of
these and in this case if you directly
apply our algorithm you get some M2 the
you can solve linear systems the linear
system you need to solve here is a
lashan linear system which we know how
to solve in your linear time so you get
something that's m to the 4/3 total run
time and we can also show that you can
improve this by using sparsifiers for
graphs so you can put this back in the
framework you put it back in the
iterative refinement framework you get
the residual problem we can use some
tools from this paper paper that
appeared in stock and that gives us parf
Fires for the residual problem and once
you have these spify you can just solve
that so it reduces to some m+ n the
43 um time algorithm for these weighted
LP Norm
FL so further work on this uh these were
for graphs so if we ask about
spcification there has been some further
work last year by um Arun Yang and Aaron
where they're able to uh reduce the
iteration complexity from m to the 1/3
to n to the 1/3 um even though we're
still using the same linear system and
they're basically basing this on um so
they have a new interpretation of Lis
weight so you can work in the smaller
space instead of the larger space in
terms of iterations the so you can
change all the potential analysis to be
working in the smaller space by just
initializing the weights to the Lis
weights instead of let's say whatever we
were using one or 1 by 10 and once you
initialize them to the Lis weights the
weights are already in the smaller space
and they also require some um new energ
some new Tools in terms of the width
reduction so the width so the weights
increase fast enough in the smaller
space right now the weights increase in
uh in terms of the m space so with these
are able to get this up to m to the
Omega into the 1/3 total time for all P
greater than
2 and so yeah this is so far the thing
we know about these parse problems
and yeah so now uh if we move on to more
algorithms in practice so from this
framework we can actually get some fast
algorithms in practice and so we look at
these uh bunch of algorithms which are
these iteratively reated Lea squares
algorithms so these basically look at
weighted linear systems and they uh
solve a different weighted linear system
in every iteration so it's kind of like
what we're doing we're handling some
weight solve a linear system and move to
the new
iteration but the standard um algorithm
just looks at this uh problem and thinks
of this as a fixed pointed rate so
instead of minimizing this it thinks of
this as a fixed Point iterate but since
we know don't know this value it
inspires this iterative
algorithm so you're looking for
something so if this is the plane you
want to find something
that yeah touches This
Plane all right so this uh since we
don't know the optim or this inspires
this fix Point iterate so you start from
some X you solve this problem you get a
new solution and you move to that
solution and you can continue this
process so this is classically known as
the iteratively relatedly squares
algorithm and it has been studied for
over 50 for over 60 years I guess 50
years and this this algorithm um it's
known to actually for small values of P
so for p between 1 and three we know
that this converges in the limit but we
don't really know the rate of
convergence but it in practice it has
been seen to converge Qui but for large
Val not even large something really
small like 3.5 you can find very easy
random instances for which this diverges
within 10 iterations and it does not so
there's basically it's it's it for a
long time we didn't really know how to
find such a weighted e squares algorithm
that converges reliably and to a any
solution
um so you can show that there's so we
can actually using this iterative
refinement framework we can find an irls
method that provably converges in very
few iterations it certainly works well
in practice because we know how to over
time we know how to solve these linear
system really fast and the rate of
convergence is not this m to the 1/3 but
you can show it converges in m to the
12 and in practice you can see that it's
much faster than the theoretical
BS and the algorithm we use is
actually not very different from the
original algorithm so instead of solving
so you solve the weighted linear system
instead of just using the weights they
use we add a small systematic value so
this s we control based on how much
progress you're making to the solution
and you use the original weights and you
just solve this and once you get a
solution instead of directly updating to
the solution you look at this
direction and you do a line search along
this direction and you find the point
which has the minimum objective value
along this direction and these two
tricks have actually been used in some
applications like this line search trick
is used usually in practice here they
sometimes add some gausian noise but
it's still not guaranteed to
convert so in this you just do this you
find a weighted linear system small
constants and if there's some
insufficient progress you control this
constant and in practice this has proved
to be pretty good
so um we look at two kinds of instances
and for to won some graph instances and
some random matrices so some random
graphs in high Dimensions some matrices
and for even large values of P you can
see that it actually converges the
error converges quite quickly you can
even get down to 10 to Theus 12 actually
you can get down to
more and in practice we also see that
the running time scales linearly with P
even though our theoretic our bound show
that it's something like P cubed or
something and with the dimension it
looks like it's almost increasing like a
constant it's not increasing too fast so
in practice it seems much much faster
than what we
find and compared to whatever algorithms
we have for these problems this was 10
to 50 times faster even on simple
computers
and
so yeah so you can see that for p equals
50 and some size
2500 can show that it converges to some
accuracy of 10 to Theus 30 in some very
few okay um so I'm now going to look at
some other approaches on obtaining these
m to the 1/3 iterations some followup
works on these and so most of
optimization
is people usually study these in the
context of these gradient descent or
these um not exactly gradient descent
but these acceleration kind of
algorithms and in
uh uh there was a work that uses this
ball Oracle approach to uh B oricle
approach that kind that gives these uh m
to the 1/3 kind of rates for um all
these quasy self concordant functions
including LP regression so this Oracle
is slightly different so we in our case
we're solving these linear systems now
they're look looking at this Oracle
where okay suppose you're given the
minimizer of a function in this uh
small in a ball of radius R then how do
you can um optimize these functions and
uh the a simple algorithm would just be
okay you take a point find this
minimizer and move to the new point and
this is can be shown to convert and
something that's yeah what's the nor oh
here I think uh at the original work
uses ukan Norm but I think they can do
it with any Norms at this
point so yeah so if so the this one
basically converges in so the initial
distance to the optimizer versus the
ball you're looking at and you can go at
a log 1 by
Epsilon and if
you you can use some Montero swier kind
of acceleration techniques and
accelerate this to some uh this value *
2/3 uh to the^ 2x 3 and you can think of
this term as something like m to the 1
12 yeah I just ra this one depends on
the norm the the the first bound does
not the second one does okay
oh yeah yeah they first so you can do
acceleration in a two Norm correct but
it's not clear in other Norms correct
you think it's
impossible uh happy to discuss after I
guess you could ask about acceleration
of L Infinity gradient descent without
when you only have a gradient Oracle
there maybe a reason but that's not a
proof and I don't think it's
not yeah what do you assume for f assume
for oh f o f here so I mean I think you
could do it for both things but if you
want to be able to implement this ball
Oracle it should um one way to implement
this ball Oracle is if f is quasy self
concordant so as we quasi self
concordance U kind of implies this local
quadratic structure right so you could
just um think of it as okay in this qu
in this ball if it has a local quadratic
stru you can use anything like
accelerated Newtons or any me to find
even very high accuracy
solution okay so yeah so using some
monos fter acceleration you can get this
down and this can be thought of as this
term can be thought of as m to the 1
half and then power 2 by3 gives you the
m and in this model there actually no
lower bounds that these kind of rates
are op there are lower bonds that which
is why and since for QSC functions this
is kind of like solving a bunch of
quadratic problems we believe the rates
are Optimum even in the multiplicative
weight
framework okay good so yeah some natural
open
problems so it's always open to figure
out whether for P1 and infinity if you
can do high accuracy with m to the 1/3
and all like show that it doesn't exist
and this would directly imply faster
linear programming but yeah or even
actually not just um P1 and infinity
it's even open to directly give m to the
1/3 kind of rates for p less than two so
you can make the iter iterative
refinement work even for p less than two
but uh we don't know how to make this
multiplicative weight update method or
any other low accuracy solver to work or
even the other algorithms that are based
on mirror procs they also work for p
greater than two and using a dual you
can do p less than two but there's no
direct method
known
and so yeah uh maybe one way to think of
finding faster ipms is if you could
actually write these algorithms as an
IPM because we know there exist m to the
1/3 higher accuracy U could ask that if
you
could write this as an IPM or something
and
the other question is okay so instead of
solving linear systems can you solve
some other um use some other Oracle like
maybe like solving a 10 Norm or
something and can you achieve
accelerated rates by that so far we only
know how to achieve this non accelerated
m to the 1 by P minus 1 by q and you may
ask can you accelerate
that and
yeah and the next talk which is is going
to be about Dynamic lease squares so we
know how to do some things for dynamic
Lee squares regession so in terms of
changing inputs we don't know much about
um any other problem so far so Still
Remains open so yeah to summarize we saw
these good envelopes for LP regression
found a fast high accuracy
algorithm and we can extend these to quy
self-concordant functions and
use inverse maintenance to get faster to
solve LP regression almost as fast as
linear regression and we also have a
fast algorithm in
practice and yeah that's
[Applause]
it questions now from the audience
additional
questions
I think this is a really naive question
but I lost where for like P being
Infinity uh why don't you get a hierarcy
algorithm by just like setting P to be
some log in log in over Epsilon or
something ah good so you have a linear
dependence on P in the algorithm right
so if you said P to be log n by Epsilon
that already gives you a one by Epsilon
oh this is like oh okay I got it okay so
it's like poly one over Epson or yeah
it's still poly one by ep
thanks
so so me just comment
there there are some settings where that
is indeed like one way to obtain an
optimal or like the best known algorithm
like this is state-ofthe-art for or was
at some point state-of-the-art for
undirected Max
flow anybody
else well it's not then we thank the
speaker
[Applause]
again is a
short